le père de stéphane est décédé dans son
testament il désigne son fils comme
unique héritier sachant que son père ne
lui laisse que des dettes
stéphane souhaite renoncer à son
héritage il rédige donc une lettre dans
laquelle il renonce au testament de son
père il fait signer cette lettre par
deux témoins mais un an plus tard revenu
québec exige qu'il rembourse la dette
que son père avait contracté de son
vivant stéphane ne s'inquiète pas et il
leur fait parvenir sa lettre de
renonciation
le problème lui dit revenu québec c'est
que ce document n'est pas valide ce que
stéphane ignorait c'est que la
renonciation à un héritage doit être
notarié le notaire publie ensuite ce
document ce qui rend la renonciation
officielle pour tout le monde y compris
les créanciers de la personne décédée
d'accord se dit stéphane je vais de ce
pas chez un notaire pour régler tout ça
sauf que malheureusement pour lui il est
trop tard il avait six mois à partir de
17 son père pour obtenir une
renonciation notarié fin mot de
l'histoire
renseignez-vous l'ignorance peut être
heureux ruineuse